[Música]
es una de las estaciones de esquí más
reconocidas de francia
e
sin embargo la nieve no es la que
diferencia a este pueblo de montaña de
todos los demás es el agua
en altura está su lago congelado que en
invierno atrae a los buzos en búsqueda
de emociones
[Música]
en el valle está la gigantesca represa
de 180 metros de alto que hace parte del
corazón de su historia
contiene 235 millones de metros cúbicos
de agua el equivalente de 75.000
piscinas olímpicas
capta también toda la atención de estos
dos empleados de electricidad de francia
dos veces al mes hacen una visita de
control en sus entrañas
vamos a bajar por la escalera de 200
peldaños que permite descender al
corazón de la represa
entonces primero controlamos todo el
resultado de los concretos es decir la
estructura de la represa y también
contamos con un sistema de auscultación
como este el sistema del péndulo que nos
permite controlar en términos generales
los desplazamientos se lo garantizo
ínfimos de la represa la represa se
mueve unos cuantos milímetros en función
de las intemperies
abajo está el ser ruido punzante el del
agua del río hice
que fluye en este gran tubo
una vez afuera es posible verlos frente
a la más elevada de las 622 represas de
francia
las obras iniciadas por electricidad de
francia empezaron en 1947 y culminaron
en 1952 se observa que el resultado fue
más que exitoso y es impresionante ha
visto desde abajo
esta construcción monumental cambió la
región
los habitantes del antiguo pueblo fueron
desalojados en 1952
[Aplausos]
y antes de la inexorable subida de las
aguas los hombres iniciaron su trabajo
de destrucción una a una cada casa
detenida fue aplastada por vol 2 ers los
últimos habitantes con sus últimos
rebaños se alejaron hacia la montaña
para iniciar una vida nueva
tiene abandona tan solo ruinas
[Música]
en altura cerca de este nuevo pueblo
moderno dedicado al esquí se esconde
otra originalidad de la estación su lago
congelado
cada mañana o gata debe romper el hielo
el problema es que tenemos bloques de
hielo que han caído
tenemos unos 5 centímetros
tocaba este hueco para practicar su
pasión bajo el hielo del lago la apnea
un sueño de niños que logró
cuando se crece en los años 80 uno ve la
película azul profundo y una de las
escenas míticas es cuando jean marc barr
observa el hielo y está extasiado
porque no intentar la aventura bajo el
hielo o parís mire a ver si es como en
azul proceso
para practicar esta disciplina extrema
hay que prepararse mentalmente
[Música]
y concentrarse en su respiración
olvidar la temperatura del agua a un
grado
pero sobre todo hay que estar en paz
[Música]
y silencio no hay nada se está solo
consigo mismo y no se puede hacer trampa
este mundo congelado atravesado por
escasos hilos de luz
trata de hacerse los descubrir a los
curiosos con alma aventurera
[Aplausos]
para lucir y nicola es su primera vez
bajo el hielo
estoy agarrada entonces nada puede pasar
son unos cuantos metros trato de mirar
bajo el hielo y luego haremos igual
lucia arranca en primer lugar trata de
seguir la cuerda de ariane que bajo el
agua sirve de referencia pero debido al
frío ya la oscuridad regresa
me dio pánico pero estoy bien y no fui
muy lejos
nicola se siente más cómodo en el agua
helada sigue a la instructora y nada
entre dos huecos en el hielo
30 segundos de apnea en un silencio
irreal
[Música]
cuando llega tiene la impresión de
regresar de un mundo paralelo
[Aplausos]
todo está bien
ok
no hay nada debajo
no se respira no se piensa se suelta
todo a gusto eso es así
la fuente del oro azul de tignes se
encuentra a tres mil 656 metros de
altura en el glaciar de la grande motte
el emblema de la estación
[Música]